yesterday nancy pelosi was asked whether
people that are politicians should be
allowed to actually hold individual
stocks or not and her answer was
absolutely absurd here is the exact
video so you yourself can go ahead and
judge for yourself madam speaker insider
just completed a five-month
investigation finding that 49 members of
congress and 182 senior congressional
staffers have violated the stock app um
the insider training law i'm wondering
if you have any reaction to that and
secondly should members of congress and
their spouses be banned from creating
individual stocks while serving congress
no i don't know to this second one um
any we have a responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month
review but if
people aren't reporting they should be
because this is a free market
we
in
people
free market economy they should be able
to participate in that what
nancy pelosi is claiming that we live in
a free market economy that is
categorically false and i can prove it
if we lived in a free market economy
then the fed and the politicians
wouldn't have stepped in and put
trillions of dollars in quantitative
easing they wouldn't have manipulated
interest rates with two emergency rate
cuts last year
on top of that if we lived in a free
market economy why is it that in our
country regulators and politicians won't
allow anyone but rich people to actually
invest in startups or private companies
the accreditation law is a perfect
example we do not live in a free economy
we live in an economy where the
government believes two things one that
they can protect you and two there
should be rules for you but not for them
it is absolutely insane that we have
politicians absolutely gaslighting
americans claiming that the reason why
they should hold individual stocks
especially stocks where they're buying
options stocks that they're buying in
the exact companies of the industries
that they are overseeing or potentially
even legislating over and their excuse
is that we live in a free market economy
i personally believe that if we lived in
a free market economy then why is it
that the politicians won't allow
everyone else to live by the same rules
that they do
that is the ultimate hypocrisy
now everyone knows that we don't live in
a free market economy and on top of that
everyone understands that if we actually
lived in a free market economy that
american citizens not the politicians
would be better off
but of course we always live in a free
market economy or at least that's what
they claim when it benefits them but the
second that that free market economy may
hurt them you know when their stock
portfolios start to go down
then all of a sudden they don't want to
live in a free market economy anymore
they want to intervene in the market
they want to manipulate interest rates
they want to go ahead and conduct
quantitative easing they want to yell
and scream and say we need to save
people people are suffering and we are
here to stop it
ultimately this is a joke that's all
that you can describe it as
politicians should not hold individual
stocks the only reason why politicians
would want to hold individual stocks is
because they want to make money and if
we have politicians that want to get
rich maybe they shouldn't be politicians
at all
a political seat is a public servant you
are elected by the people to represent
us we do not elect you to go and get
rich we do not elect you so that you can
get inside information and go ahead and
trade on it instead what you should
focus on is not what your portfolio is
doing or what stocks you own or what
your annualized return is but instead
you should actually spend time
representing us
and so ultimately to solve this problem
we should just pay the politicians a
bigger salary pay them all five million
dollars each [ __ ] they're creating
trillions of dollars where's that all go
somehow they're trying to get in their
pocket anyways so let's just give them
the five million dollars of annual
salary and tell them you're not allowed
to own individual stocks you're not a
lot of trade you're not allowed to do
anything that potentially could be seen
as being unethical
ultimately we've seen central bankers
they had this problem we had central
bankers that were day trading the exact
same assets they were purchasing on
behalf of the central bank it's absurd
but we need to have a louder voice these
politicians have lost their minds
they're continuing to buy and sell the
very same stocks they legislate and any
time that you have somebody who's going
options and leverage long
you got to start asking yourself
what gives the politician the expertise
to do that
why are they so sure in those financial
investments it's been a long time since
we've seen a politician
be a bad investor i've never heard of a
politician losing money as an investor
maybe that's the exact problem is that
when you're a politician and you're
allowed to buy individual stocks you
essentially have a risk-free trading
environment you have a risk-free
investment you know what's going to
happen because you're the one who has a
big hand in making it happen and that's
the problem
now i don't agree with aoc on a lot of
things but on this we see eye to eye aoc
had a great point she's got the tweet
here that says it absolutely ludicrous
that members of congress can hold and
trade individual stocks while in office
the access and influence we have should
be exercised for the public interest not
our profit it shouldn't be legal for us
to trade individual stocks with the info
that we have
ultimately that's what i believe as well
this is insane and nancy pelosi is flat
out wrong